why don't we go next to Simon from
Montana Simon welcome to the program uh
what's going on in Montana can you hear
me yes I can
oh that's awesome
um a long time viewer I really love your
show and I look forward to it every day
well I appreciate that what what's it
like living in Montana I have a friend
who's a doctor who does medicine
seasonally in Montana and finds it a
very very interesting place
oh um that's that's awesome uh do you
know what town he lives in well I don't
want to say
oh yeah because it's so rural there that
there might only be 10 people in that
town and everyone will know who I'm
talking about you know
yeah yes absolutely well it's very cold
right now
um and yeah a lot of a lot of red I live
in sort of a blue bubble in
um one of the two blue bubbles I will
say so you don't have like a 45 minute
drive to get groceries or anything like
that
no it's it's pretty good here for sure
it's all right if you want to go to like
Europe do you have to what you fly to
like Chicago and then Chicago to Europe
or is it more complicated than that
um well our airport goes I would say
generally we take our airport to yeah
somewhere like I guess Spokane or
something like that is generally where
I've been going huh but from Spokane I
can't imagine you're getting to London
for example right oh no
um well I've only been to Mexico out of
the country I believe we went somewhere
near Spokane fair and then yeah well
what's I've had so many questions it
seems only fair to allow you to ask one
well thank you I appreciate them
um and I I was just I've been wondering
for the last couple weeks I know you've
talked about the migrant bussing stunts
that are absolutely disgusting yeah and
horrible deplorable
um and I just wanted to know obviously
these people like Greg Abbott and
DeSantis are doing it because they feel
like it scores them political points
with their base right um otherwise they
wouldn't continue to do it I was
wondering like
as the left as a media sphere what can
we do to prevent us to stop that or or I
think we should be aiming resources at
preventing this from being something
that scores them political points
because obviously so horrifying if it
doesn't score them political points so
so here's the issue if it does score
them political points I don't know that
the left can do much about that because
it's working and their constituents like
it I do think being on the same page
about explaining why it's deplorable and
disgusting makes sense so that hopefully
people who hear about it that might say
oh that's interesting that proves a
point then they hear oh actually here's
why it's crazy and it's financially a
disaster and it's immoral and it's
unethical and it's treating people like
objects and and pawns Etc but what
really we need is an electorate where it
wouldn't score the many points so it's a
much broader change that needs to be
affected
yeah yeah it's definitely a bit of a
wicked issue there and um yeah so well
yeah that was pretty much all that's on
my mind and it really is like I'm a big
strong guy but with tears in my eyes it
is an honor to talk to you so and just
last thing can you get a good bagel in
Montana
oh God no sir okay thank you very much
well now I'm the one who has tears in
his eyes thanks thanks for the call
Simon I appreciate it of course all
right we're gonna take the quickest of
breaks if you're still holding we're
going right back to the phones so I
would I would suggest that you stay with
me here very quick break and then we
will be right back and hear from more of
you might remember that a few years ago
uh the show got hacked and many
thousands of dollars were stolen we
never got it back it's a terrible
feeling it can happen to anyone but a
couple of years ago we got Aura which
really gives us significantly more peace
of mind and our sponsor Aura is the app
that protects you from scammers by
alerting you anytime your info like
email passwords social security number
are found in data breaches or also
automatically requests removal of your
info from search engines and it can
reduce spam calls Aura alerts you
quickly about suspicious credit
inquiries like if someone tries to take
a loan out in your name and or as
password manager makes it easy to keep
your account secure to begin with aura
also has parental controls for your kids
devices you can restrict apps or manage
screen time set Focus time make sure
they're doing homework instead of
binging on YouTube you can try Aura free
for 14 days at aura.com
use the free trial to see if your email
password are already out there you may
be surprised the link is down below